yeah I think out my flaws they going to
run with
me and I think you know embracing your
flaws figuring out like kind of
understanding what they are that's the
problem I got with this game today
bro I'm one of them [__] I ain't
always been a standup guy in every
situation
oh I ain't always been right that's
important to admit man that's what every
[__] man no you're right though like
you know me being here had I you just
reached out to me one day I don't know
what interview you saw mine but you just
had asked me like do you enjoy what you
do and it was randomly you and I have
never
met um and I just hit you like hey dude
I'd love to talk to you one day and you
know we made it happen so I I appreciate
you uh opening up your home to me and
um you know inviting me out to Utah man
it is cold as hell out
here I almost ate [__] on a I wouldn't
call it a snowmobile it's like a snow
scooter um a moon a moon bike whatever a
moon bike that [__] had me [__] up my
legs are really wet right now um for you
man talk about just like you say your
legs wet oh yeah my shit's all the way
up to here I don't want [__] ass with
then I mean we're we are kind of sitting
on a freshly clean couch ring that hor
yeah in the couch is got clean that's
why we sitting on knes it's damp for
sure we're we're damp right now we're
just in the snow 100% real talk um I was
going to ask you man like uh somebody
who I think you who was
also very
anti-industry but is also very
successful right now and you have such a
great chemistry and working relationship
you guys got a couple of songs that I
love is
rodwave he is an amazing guy he's from
St Pete which I lived there for a long
time that's somebody who feel a win in
the game
like I think he love what he do he's so
good at it man and I think he's so
positive
and
so taking in a people ain't no way he
could
feel that's real you've been known to do
a collab project here or there would you
guys ever do a whole uh whole tape
together maybe like a little EP or
something I think that'll be a setback
for him you think so my image [__] up
I got I think I got to stay in my own
lane that's fair you guys do got some
great couple great joints together
though he's how often are you like
discovering new artists cuz obviously
you have your crew you have your label
like your artist but are you do you
listen to much other music outside of
your own stuff or your own guys like are
you tapped into like not really I know
about a lot of artists though that I
think the world don't know about
well they I just say they underground
but I like e you like E I was saying
like they like e okay I don't think he
underground no more he was but he's not
now yeah and I think it's a lot of more
artist like that that's to come yeah
there's like guys like destroy lonely
and ye and yeah it's the lonely hard
yeah know um
yeah I feel like there's a difference
between being like underground because
you're not necessarily commercial but I
think once you get to the point where
you're get in a billion streams I don't
know how underground you could be you
know cuz I think some people still
consider you who are like just generic
music
fans they might think that you're kind
of like underground but you're not
you're one of the biggest artists in the
world you know what I mean so that's
because they live in a different
world that's true they not into they not
into nothing like
me I mean you are 101 man I say that